harry wilde est d'arriver chez les innus
du lac saint jean il y à 25 en algonquin
cris de l'abitibi l'artiste peintre
s'est présentée au musée amérindien de
mashteuiatsh en quête d'un emploi
c'est ici qu'on lui a donné sa première
chance c'est un valeur du sein est un
bon moyen pour se faire connaître aussi
parce que quand tu connais ma blonde
comme pour harry des dizaines de
citoyens de la communauté travaillent
ici boulot c'est à un des plus utilisés
pour tous mais pour s'abonner ou si
certains employés restent au fil du
temps comme patrice devenu guide en
raison de sa passion pour ses origines
mais aussi grâce à son indéniable talent
de conteur
tu peux faire des choses hallucinantes
une peine avec ceux d'hiver damas et je
passe les pelles à neige était
indispensable
comment être sûr prendre une apparence
sortie manquée tomber sur des paiements
je sens que je t'aime a placé qu'en juin
quand j'explique que ces choses là on
n'a pas besoin de montrer aux jeunes
comment joue nintendo dans d'aubin xbox
le 1 mais c'est pour la culture ça se
perd vite c'est une pratique paul
personne n'en parle jamais mais certains
gays dont l'expérience de la vie comme
bagage mais les plus jeunes doivent être
formés après leur embauche
les critère numéro un pour l'emploi la
passion dont nous que son conte leur
donnant ce coup quax sur la culture
quelle est la place de la culture dans
dans leur vie parce que ce qu'on veut
qu'il vive comme témoignage quand y
travaillons nous et ce par les deux
autres de ce qu'ils vivent puis parler
de la culture mais que ce soit naturel
prosodie est fausse
[Applaudissements]
et le musée contribuer à la
consolidation et à la re découverte de
cette culture
chaque été du personnel passe du musée
au terrain en 2010 est une hache vieille
de 5000 ans a été trouvé un master
viatte ce qui démontre l'importance du
site
parfois réceptionniste et responsable de
l'accueil vienne calhoun hier à ans de
participer aux fouilles archéologiques
c'est plus de plumes à mon panache plus
d'expérience je peux largement charles
expertise c'est pour ça que j'ai très
trash minutieuse et sauf nouvelle
découvert ceux qui travaillent au musée
continue de partager leur art ou leur
savoir harry lui expose ses peintures
ici mais de nous céder cours à petit
écran
j'en attends une baisse entre temps donc
on ne trouvera plus à partager texte un
mode de vie pourquoi parce qu'en forêt
et les familles se rencontrent est ce
arrivé ce pas donc je partageais
repensant consiste donc la tradition
s'habituer mais d'une autre manière et
ses milices à vos souhaits radio-canada
match de vias